اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد سته
فلسطينيين برصاص قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في عمليه عسكريه نفذتها في مخيم الجنين
بعد ظهر اليوم وقالت الوزاره ان العمليه
ادت ايضا الى اصابه سته عشر فلسطينيا
بجروح في حين اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل
اربعه فلسطينيين خلال هذه العمليه التي
قال انها مرتبطه بمقتل مستوطنين اثنين في
حواره بالضفه الغربيه الشهر الماضي
معنى الالم من رام الله مراسله الجزيره
جيفارا البوديري جيفارا الحصيله اذا
ارتفعت الى سته شهداء وسته عشر جريحا حسب
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه في عمليه اسرائيل
الاخيره في مخيم جنين ضعينا في صوره
الاوضاع الان وهل هدات الامور في المدينه
الان قوات الاحتلال فعليا انسحبت بالكامل
من داخل مخيم ومحيط مخيم جنين والمدينه
بالطبع وفق المعلومات المحدثه هناك تاكيد
رسمي اسرائيلي باصابه جنديين اسرائيليين
بجراح مختلفه وكان هناك سياره اسعاف
اسرائيليه قد وصلت الى حاجه زائد غربي
جنين وقامت بنقل الجريحين من الجنود
الاحتلال الى منطقه خارج جنين ما اكدته
حتى اللحظه وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
باستشهاد سته فلسطينيين واصابه اكثر من
ثمانيه ابن 16
فلسطينيا بجراح مختلفه هناك حاله دمار
كبيره جدا في المنزل الذي كان محاصر واضح
ان قوات الاحتلال اطلقت صواريخ يدويه اي
على الكتف اتجاه المنزل الذي كان محاصر
وفق وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه فمن بين
الشهداء السته تردد اسم عبد الفتاح خريشه
قوات الاحتلال تزعم بانه من نفذ عمليه
حواره قبل عشره ايام تقريبا والتي ادت الى
مقتل مستوطنين اثنين في بلده حواره وواضح
ان تمكن هذا الفلسطيني من الوصول من حواره
والانتقال الى داخل مخيم جنين اعتبره كثير
من المحللين انه حتى صباح هذا اليوم كان
هناك فشل امني اسرائيلي ولكن انصحت هذه
المعلومات فبالفعل الان قوات الاحتلال
وصلت الى منفذ الهجوم في داخل المخيم
بالطبع هناك حاله دمار شامل وكبيره جدا
ايضا في المنازل المحيطه بالمنزل الذي كان
محاصر لان هذا المنزل ومنازل اخرى ايضا
كانت محاصره من قبل قوات الاحتلال التي
استخدمت مروحيه عسكريه ولكن ايضا مقاومون
فلسطينيون تمكنوا من اسقاط مسيرتين اما
كانتا تستخدم هذه المسيرتين للتصوير على
الارض او اطلاق الرصاصه من السماء ولكن
حتى الان هناك وقبل قليل انطلقت مسيره
يشارك فيها الالاف من الفلسطينيين اتجاه
المستشفى مستشفى ابن سينا وايضا باتجاه
مخيم جنين
واضح ان التحضيرات ايضا تجرى لتشييع
الشهداء السته لا نعرف ان كان العدد
سيرتفع لان هناك لا زالت اصابات في غرف
العمليات رغم ان الحديث عن اصابات متوسطه
وطفيفه ولكنها كلها بالرصاص الحي وحاله من
الغليان السياسي ايضا فالرئاسه الفلسطينيه
حملت المسؤوليه الكامله للحكومه
الاسرائيليه سر اللجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه
التحرير حسين الشيخ اكد بان اسرائيل تحاول
تصدير ازماتها الداخليه الى الاراضي ايضا
القياده الفلسطينيه طالبت الولايات
المتحده بالتدخل الفوري لان اسرائيل تحاول
افشال كل الجهود السياسيه المبذوله لوقف
التصعيد على الارض والخارجيه الفلسطينيه
تؤكد بان اسرائيل تحاول تحويل وتواصل
تحويل الاراضي الفلسطينيه والضفه الغربيه
تحديدا الى ساحه صراع متواصل نواصل معك
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات من
رام الله